good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack Van Horn
from the University of Virginia and I'm very
proud to welcome you to this first edition of our
2023 2024 foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA College of Arts and Sciences
the UVA School of data science and through a
grants from the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 20 2016 the foundations
of biomedical data science seminar Series has
focused on the use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to differing
themes in biomedicine and the Health Sciences
this year's theme is building Partnerships for
generative AI training in biomedical and clinical
research where we will enjoy presentations on
Fridays from leading thinkers about the issues the
promise the opportunities and hurdles associated
with the emerging methods in AI based Technologies
applied to biomedical science data types and the
efforts by faculty Educators in training the next
generation of biomedical researchers to properly
use those computational tools indeed today we are
excited to announce that we are opening our 2023
2024 application cycle encouraging Junior
faculty members working in the area such
as the development of generative AI B based
methods applied to biomedical research and
those Junior faculty actively utilizing AI in
their biomedical teaching to consider applying
we believe this will be an exciting and engaging
program bringing together AI platform developers
and University Educators to better understand
the power the promise and the potential perils
associated with Gen the generative AI explosion
participants selected for a biomedical data
science Innovation lab program will leverage
these seminar presentations as vital material
for our culminating inperson manuscript and Grant
generation project uh to be held at the Bahia
beachfront Resort located in Sunny San Diego
California in June of 2023 2024 my apologies
today I am delighted to welcome our speaker Dr
Brian Wright from the UVA School of data science
uh Dr Wright is a 2024 BDS mentor and he is an
associate professor and director of undergraduate
programs at the UVA School of data science
prior to this appointment Dr was the director
of George Washington University's graduate data
science programs and served as a faculty member
teaching machine learning introduction to data
science and Capstone courses on an annual basis
he also helped to co-found George Washington
University's data Science Institute and prior to
joining George Washington Dr Wright organized and
led interdisciplinary teams of researchers at the
University of Texas at Knoxville he is the founder
of DS Labs LLC and a data science uh consultancy
that focuses on educational program development
algorithm construction and data science focused
research and development efforts his research sits
at the center of education and data science and
he holds degrees in economics Public Health
Administration and uh higher education he is
currently working to develop predictive
algorithms to increase Algebra 1 success
in K through 12 settings in initiating the 2023
2024 biomedical data science seminar series theme
Brian's lecture today is entitled generative a
AI in context Professor Wright will talk about
the road that led to the incredible explosion of
generative AI that we are currently experiencing
and that has rapidly emerged over the past couple
of years creating new research communities around
developing adversarial neural networks and
large language models the results from which
have recently proven disruptive across public
scientific and educational Spectrum in particular
he'll talk about highlevel architectures that
allow for large language models to be so effective
and conclude with implications for research moving
forward as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via YouTube If you are
watching on YouTube thank you so much for joining
us also our specially selected 2023 2024 by a
medical data science Innovation lab participants
in alumni are encouraged to submit any questions
via the chat feature in their YouTube sessions I
will be synthesizing these questions and will'll
ask them on your behalf during the last 10 minutes
or so of the lecture and with that welcome Brian
thank you so much for kicking us off this year we
look forward to your lecture thanks for that uh
generous introduction Jack and I'm happy to be
here and uh let's go ahead and Jump Right In I
got I got one quick change for the introduction
you said University of Texas that's University of
Tennessee I beg your partner Tennessee no no no
I my uh my fellow colleagues from there would
be uh would be remiss if I didn't jump in but
anyway um thanks again jack uh this is great so
I I'm just going to go over um this uh kind of
agenda here real quick uh going to lay out a
little bit of data science Concepts uh I got
a little bit of a poll I think for the audience
too because I'm not totally sure um kind of the
level of expertise I'm dealing with here so I
can adjust the the talk a little bit based off
those responses but the meat of it here is kind
of oriented around how did we get here um uh so
I'll talk about the evolution of the field uh a
little bit of history but we'll get through it
real quick and then we'll talk specifically about
kind of large language models and the current you
know generative AI boom that we have and and to
Jack's Point kind of end with some concerns so
here I have a quick poll you can hit the QR
code up there you can think of this as like
a scale from top to bottom you know that you what
is your experience in terms of relative knowledge
of data science you know if you feel like you
you embody data science wholly you can hit that
first one but if you're not sure about the field
you're just getting started maybe you're all the
way down there on the bottom uh and that'll just
help me kind of context the the talk in general
so there we go all right we do have one person
that is embodying data ass signs that's good to
know okay very good I'll give it a few minutes
there's probably a bit of a lag and we're not
totally sure how many people we have on the other
end but we'll go from go from what responses we
get there we go okay we got a
couple more people I've been
using ml for many years all right very good right
been planning to use it for
many years all right very
good give it a few more moments
here see if we get some more
responses
all right well let's let's go ahead and move on it
might be that we get a few more people that jump
on that poll kind of as we move throughout but
that's that's no problem so it looks like it's
kind of a kind of a split right so all right we
got one more all right so we got a little bit of
a this data science thing you say all right uh
so I'll probably jump through maybe some of the
front end ones but kind of stick to the original
plan here uh so let's give just a quick overview
of some of these data science Concepts so in
particular here at this at UVA we have kind of
this uh Paradigm that we have embodied about the
way we think of the field of data science and it's
composed of these four components I'm not going
to get into this there's a whole dissertation
associated with this but in large part what we're
talking about large language models generative AI
it's in this analytics category you know value
you can think of Ethics systems you can think
of cloud computing design you can think of data
visualizations or human centered design so that's
the way that we think about it um in the school we
have curriculum kind of designed around that but
you know in this particular talk especially as it
relates to AI we're focusing on that and analytics
piece and again based off those responses I think
a lot of people are familiar with this but I like
to break down analytics just to think of it not
just as machine learning but there's also these
components of Applied Mathematics all right
statistical Concepts and then and then AI all
right so AI is the Big 10 I think that's going to
spin uh and so when we think about that all right
again just given the diversity of the audience
right artificial intelligence is the big is the
big sector all right machine learning is a subset
of artificial intelligence artificial intelligence
going to be everything from just simple software
engineering that helps um that helps computers
think like humans right that might be coding
certain uh as an example coding certain interfaces
between um various medications to make sure that
there's not any type of conflict to prescribe
those to uh to individual patients that doesn't
require any type of fancy machine learning that's
just simple software all right but that helps in
decision making right machine learning when we
go down inside the AI Spectrum we think of that
as kind of more like probability istic learning
like what are you know kind of learning without
being specifically coded and then deep learning
which is where kind of the big boom associated
with AI and generative AI in particular is really
the focus of this particular year um for this
program and then also kind of the focus of the
talk so it just helps contextualize that for
everybody and it sounds like you know a good
amount of people on The Talk know this but the
context with which we're talking about this deep
learning is actually kind of a very small portion
it is the one that gets the most attention by far
but it is a smaller portion um of a larger big AI
10 all right I just went through these so I don't
have to dig too much more into that but these
are kind of General examples of like classical
AI machine learning that might be just product
recommendations and then deep learning is really
the kind of the large language models or neural
network applications in particular all right okay
so this is important context to is we go further
down right in terms of like the the level of AI
you just have a more predictive power but they're
less explainable so explainable should be on the
bottom on the bottom bar there and we're going
to send most of our time up in the top this is
just a look again across the landscape of machine
learning and you can see kind of in the bottom
there that neural networks all right is kind of
a subset of the larger world of machine learning
and this chart's a little old it probably should
be updated um in particular to add some of the
new methods um that are starting to come out okay
okay so um important part here to keep in context
you we think of machine learning as really kind
of a general purpose technology that means they
can apply it across all sorts of different Market
sectors you know whether you want to elevate it to
the level of electricity in the internet maybe not
but anyway that's the way that we think of it so
again in good context and part of the reason that
we're here is to learn about how we can apply in
particular to biomedical situations all right I'm
going to skip over that all right and these are
just kind of contemporary points all right so
what we've seen especially over you know since
2010 there was this big com of um Milestone there
associated with the error rate of classification
and image net it went way down you know less
than 5% and the important part behind that is
that's because that's um that's lower than the
human error rate all right so what we know is
as humans were to look at this there's about a 5%
error so it got below kind of the human error rate
and that started happen around 2010 one of these
first big deep uh Learning Systems was deep blue
that was purchased there's a European company
that ended up getting purchased by Google it's
kind of the corner St of their um you know Aid
driven efforts internally um and then you know
as we move along what we found and this is just
recently there's been another the same that same
product right that deep blue kind of deep level
architecture was used in in another game for go
um that is much more complicated than chess right
and then that that Alpha go was the product that
was generated there but just recently um you know
a simple trick by an amateur was able to beat the
computer I think 18 out of 19 times right happened
sometime in the last six months and so no matter
how good um I think anyway no matter how good
these machines get and they're approving just
at an incredible scale all right there still is
some need for human expertise and experience along
the way so I think it's an important reminder as
we go through all of this we have really Advanced
obviously machine learning and generative AI
product tools but there's still kind of uh use
cases and examples where if we just keep human in
the loop that they end up working better or they
can kind of beat them even if the most Advanced
even if the most advanced uh examples of that all
right so uh again this is just kind of context
these are things that our humans are good at but
this is things that machines are good at and again
kind of interpreting and using the results I think
is the key one with the check mark under the human
there that we should keep in mind all right so I
blew through that really quick I always uh always
look for excuses to build in uh Back to the Future
memes so there's one here so the question is
like how did we get to this point all right
so let's let's take a a look at that oh this
is much fuzzier than I thought it would be but
this is generally a timeline associated with the
development of intelle know AI based Frameworks
over time uh and what we'll see right especially
towards the end here all right all right it's kind
of a rapid development in terms of the integration
between machine learning developed kind of in the
private sector and then in combination with what's
going on in uh the academic all right so let me
let just jump ahead of this and I think right
here right I mean the main takeaway from this
and again this is what most people are kind of
familiar with this the nature of this is that a
lot of these artificial intelligence Methods
at least the foundation of them had been in
development or at least um Being Framed out in uh
academic circles for decades you know as far back
as the 1960s all right but it really wasn't until
the first part this of the 2010s right when they
started to get a ton of notice um from the private
sector about how powerful these tools could be as
it relates to leveraging the business models that
were occurring especially in the you know kind of
social media and um you know internet search
engine world all right and so right about this
time 20 2009 2012 what we start to see is kind
of this combination of all this long Heritage
of academic work all right starting to create um
really um momentum inside the big Tech firms of
the day and so a lot of people point to this kind
of 200 n you know when Al Val Herring started to
come out and talk about kind of you know that that
the you know Google's Chief Economist saying hey
that this is going to be you know statisticians
are going to be in high demand and then there's
kind of this famous article in 2012 the Harvest
Business Review that called data scientist kind
of the sexist job in the 21st century so all
these years of progression right kind of led
up to kind of this fluctuation point where
popular kind of um attention in the in the
media and in the private sector really started
to notice about how important these things were
going to be be all right and there's there's a
bunch of reasons for this this is just to take
note of of hinton's influence in terms of this
timeline right the the amount of contribution
that he made throughout is not to be understated
and so we can take a look at this timeline right
to just put it in more context if you haven't been
to this before this is this is an engram viewer um
from Google and essentially tracks word usage
over time in their digital libraries all right
so here what we're searching for is artificial
intelligence data science machine learning and
maybe to nobody's surprise right and just to
reinforce the ideal that we were talking about
here is that you know there was this big bump you
know even back in the in the 1990s right and then
again in kind of the early 2000s um and but it
went up and down right and so the question is and
people refer to these as kind of the AI Winters
but I put some I put some stars in here and I'm
going to try and contextualize I think why and
maybe it's obvious but why exactly we saw kind
of this recent takeoff and then how all of this
history kind of built up to this this moment in
2015 that really that really catapulted us into
this generative AI space so let's talk about that
in particular all right all right so here right
early 2000s I think you know a derivative of a
little bit of an increase there is what we saw is
the you know the mass production of Nvidia gpus
that started to happen right at the beginning
of the 2000s and as we know like a lot of these
big data and especially these deep architectures
really depend on now they they've moved on right
to New U more advanced kind of Hardware but
that started to help us realize the power of
these models that just wasn't available before all
right so we had kind of a hardware contribution in
the early 2000s and we saw kind of a spike there
right after that all right it's kind a housing
bubble everything went down after that that's
an excuse for maybe the the kind of reduction
that we saw all right so we had we had a lot of
these U mathematical softwares been developed or
mathematical procedures that had been developed
in academic uh circles for years all right but
then we had this Hardware contribution and then
we saw a software contribution that allowed us
to link distributed networks together efficiently
all right that hadn't been available really before
there would been methods before but spark in
particular allowed us to really combine this
kind of computing architectures in combination
with the hardware all right those two things
together really kind of laying the foundation
for what would be just a perfect development
environment kind of leading into the 2015s all
right and so here I think is really where we
saw kind of this punctuated equilibrium all right
so we have we had Hardware that was in place that
could that could support the computational needs
that were necessary all right we saw some of this
open source software that allowed those computers
to be linked together in uh in sophisticated ways
that hadn't been available before at least it
became much more efficient and then also right
around this time like right around 2015 the
accumulation of data uh starts to really take
off um it had always been growing right through
the early 2000s especially with the creation of
the internet a lot of people point to the create
um the mass production of uh iPhones in the early
2010s as a real dramatic increase in the amount
of available data and so there's statistics here
right in 2009 that 90% of the world's data have
been created basically in the last three or four
years and you can see that with the explosion of
internet based companies right with the explosion
of mobile um Hardware and cell phones that was a
huge point right so we had we had the hardware in
place we had kind of an ability to connect those
together and now what we've seen over that period
right after that is this massive expansion in
data right and so at that same time Google and
they were kind of you know one of the first to
field here right with their deep blue engine they
see these massive increases in the performance
of their AI based platforms right and so as a
catalyst to that and I think it's because of that
as I mentioned kind of preceding this slide with
about how things were folding out in the private
sector in combination with the uh you know kind
of contemporary media around Ai and data science
you saw academic institutions starting to respond
dramatically to the demand from the private sector
to create degrees to support the expansion of this
Workforce so at that same time right in 2012 20
you know leading up to 2015 we see a huge increase
especially in the graduate programs Masters in
data science Masters in Business analytics it
just it just went crazy and in combination with
that the demand signal from the research Community
also increased dramatically as it you know I think
as a as a driving force for some of these big Tech
firms they were doing their own internal research
incubators right they were really trying to put
a lot of phds um you know a lot of human capital
in the development of these Technologies because
they started to see really crazy increases in the
performance of their models right in that period
of time so to reinforce this uh ideal I have
here the same thing if we add data set to that
distribution that you just saw it's exact same
as this we just added the word data set it just
dwarfs the others there right so the expansion
of data if this is a measure of how often that
is used in public discourse which is supposed
to be we can see that this you know the increase
here just dwarfs the kind of the percentage
increases we see in these other three areas
to reinforce the idea of the massive amount of
increases of data that was occurring right at
that same time all right so this is a chart from
Michael Raa he was one of the first uh analytics
programs really kind people some some say one
of the first data science specific programs at
NC State and he's been tracking the increase in in
graduate programs over the last I mean 12 years so
here you can see again right around that 2014 2015
time frame it's just an explosion in the number of
programs from 2010 which might be less than 20
you know to to to 2015 where you're looking at
200 and then moving into 300 and then continuing
to grow uh into the early 2020 so that reinforces
this idea you know this second bullet here about
this dramatic increase in the workforce that we
saw all right this is a chart from from Springer
they're tracking kind of Big Data Publications
that were occurring over time and again it
right here in that same sweet spot you know
2010 to 2019 you just see this huge increase in
the number of Publications I mean from down there
in the zeros to up to you know pushing 8,000 in a
period of what five or six years I mean so again
it's this combination of investment from from the
private sector attention from Academia and kind
of leveraging these uh methods that already been
placed for a long time the increases that we saw
in availability of data and then the you know the
the Computing infrastructure both in hardware and
software that were available be able to Catalyst
it just created this perfect incubator for this
explosion in methods all right and it's all kind
of leading up to this AI Revolution that we've
seen over the last I don't know two to three years
and so the question is and leading into this kind
of Stark um increase in artificial intelligence
what is that what is that particular star so let's
let's get a little bit more detailed in the terms
of what we're thinking about for generative AI in
particular and then and then and actually
specifically kind of large language models
okay all right so a lot of the work here I
just wanted to give Credence to uh to Raphael
Alvarado he put a lot of this together he's an
anthropologist but specializes in kind of text
analysis here in the school of data science so he
let me borrowed some of his some of his slides for
this but they're they're perfectly gerine for
this talk so I'm going to include him there so
thanks Raph for that I appreciate it all right
so let's talk about large language models in
particular okay so uh you know based off what we
know right so um more specifically these large
language models what they're doing is they're
really trying to predict the next token all right
which is really just another word right so they're
autoaggressive so they're very dependent on what
happened right before that next prediction but
they can use billions of weights all right inside
these deep neural networks Frameworks okay but
it all boils down to basically trying to predict
what the next word is oh my God the volcano is
about to right erupt all right so in this examp
I just wanted to lay that context is that it can
be distilled down just into that simple output
obviously the architectures that underneath these
things are quite complicated but the idea is just
to predict kind of the next sequence of words all
right now this is an example of what a gp2 right
this is an older version of it that can actually
be run just on a desktop but just to reinforce
this idea right so what you see down here on the
bottom all right this is a this is a Transformer
that's the architecture the AI architecture
associated with this particular particular
this particular framework and that's the same
framework that supports GPT and chat and it's
and the application chat GPT all right but here
what we're doing is we're trying to predict the
next word you can see down here in this sentence
the best thing about AI is its ability to and then
what's going to happen is that you're going to
have essentially a vector here right of different
words and their likelihood to show up based off
the um based off the data that this architecture
has in place what is the most likely word to show
up next in this sequence of words all right and
what we're doing is we're outputting here just
the top probability we're just doing the top 20
probabilities here and they're not in order I
probably should have should have done that but
what we'll see here is its ability to learn is
actually the next best object but at the end of
the day right if you distill these down that's
the goal right is them for them to them to to
be able to predict essentially what this next
token is going to be uh based off the previous
uh set of words that it's given and and it does a
really good job about this so if we look back like
at the technologies that support it one of the
key ones and again these are there's a list here
but in 2013 all right word DEC was invented all
right which is an important part but also it was
followed up by um something called the distribut
uh distributional hypothesis right and that the
idea behind the distributional hypothesis and
I think I have a slide to it so I'll talk a
little bit more to that is that words that are
close together have similar meaning and they
can be predicted based off the VAR based off the
various distance the likelihood that they far far
apart they are in large corai of text so this is
important right so we realize that okay we don't
have to actually create you know fairly structured
models to be able to interpret grammar we can just
use essentially the location of the words as
a vehicle for predicting how good it will fit
in the next sentence right so this distributional
hypothesis this was key to kind of creating these
large language models and as we look through these
sequence of things again I just want to highlight
a few of these all right not to talk through
them and a naum in 2014 attention was created
as basically another hyperparameter associated
with um large language models and attention is
essentially you can think of it as the emphasis
on any one word the importance of any one word in
a sentence all right uh and so if you can assign
attention so there's different there's different
examples of this so if we to say you know the cat
is black all right so in that particular sentence
right the word black is very important for cat
right but if we were to say as an example you
know there's both a a black cat and a white cat
it might be that the distribution associated with
those two words white and black are equal as
compared to more attention that was given on
the first sentence that might be a bad example
but the idea of it is a essentially how much um
how important is any one word to understanding the
entire string of words in which it's embedded all
right and so Transformers were also invented
in 2017 all right which is a new architecture
associated with essentially it was designed to
translate language but much of that architecture
actually the the majority of that architecture is
what used under the hood for large language models
uh currently in terms of their generating um terms
of their applications particularly in GPT right
so it's used there so it's the kind of the AI
architecture driving a lot of the a lot of these
large language models and what we found right
is that uh instead of uh including a lot of the
other parameters associated with how these models
are trained is that attention ends up being kind
of the key component right so these Transformers
helped us move away from recurring neural networks
as a baseline architecture for um generative
large language models and then attention which
was created in 2014 ended up being the key
component in order for them to really perform
at a high level so it's really these combinations
of things it's attention mechanism all right and
then also this new architecture associated with
Transformers that allowed us to kind of move
forward in this GPT world and we can see right
after this in 2018 new TBT is pre-trained with
a Transformer model all right and then Bert and
Google suddenly they're announcing to they're
moving off of recurring neural networks and
using this Transformer model with that attention
component and then it just kind of skyrockets
from there and so gpt2 is the one that I showed
kind of in the snapshot there about the way it's
predicting just with the probabilities but a lot
of these um components put themselves in place
right in combination I talked about this so I
think I'll skip over this all right in combination
with these features right in the timeline that we
talked about here right so what we saw and that's
what the question mark is there really that's the
Transformer and attention architectures so we
have had again not to review it all but we had
all of these components that kind of came together
at this like perfect moment right where they saw
like really these increases in Ai and then we had
the correct architecture that was that was able
to take advantage of all this previous work and
that's why we saw this just massive increase in
the in the use and proliferation of AI we know we
had this you know kind of you know generative AI
Revolution that we're in for the last two years
it's kind of a combination of all this kind of
slow burn and then suddenly right there kindor
right in 2017 and 18 is when things just went
just went through the roof all right so let's talk
a little bit more about how these models work and
I think it's important to just contextualize
that that there's one other component of the
of the large language models that's really
important I think I put it here so there's
kind of these three key enhancements right so we
talked about attention and then there's position
that's basically the position of the words that's
kind of the word to vet concept and there's also
this thing thing called temperature all right so
if you understand these three things about these
um Transformer models these large langu large
language models right then you kind of have a
general high level idea about how they're working
all right so attention is an important one and so
what attention tells us is essentially what order
that we're going to select the next probable the
next probabilistic word to choose right and
that's that's kind of a word salad there but
the idea is that it's not it might not always be
best to pick the word with the highest probability
is that you might have to adjust and this is
what the temperature does essentially adjusts
you know uh at random how random we want that
next word to be as compared to just picking the
top probability which in this example would be
would be learn all right so this is an example
so I just again we let this run a little bit more
right so here we was just continuing to build out
this is build out this large language model you
can see we're adding you know new words step by
step learn from experience it's not just it's not
just a matter of all right so we're basically just
letting this run to add another 10 words to it
but what we find is that if we don't adjust the
temperature this is the result we get all right
so this is an example from from Steven Wolfram all
right so he did he went through this experiment
and showed this online and the idea here is that
if the temperature is set to zero that means that
it takes the top probabilistic word that is that
is predicted uh every time what happens is is you
get this you start to see essentially uh just a a
repetition all right it just starts to repeat in
a cycle because the next likely word is going to
be based off what was done before and if there's
no variability it's just going to start to repeat
so we see that here this is a temperature of
zero all right but if we increase this is a
temperature of 08 you can go from 0 to one in most
of these models what we see is a much more elegant
sentence all right so here what it's doing is it's
randomly selecting all right from that list of
possible words not choosing the top possible
word and that's what generates this type of
much more kind of elegant sentence and this was an
advancement that allowed for large language models
to really produce high quality text in combination
with the new Transformer architecture and then
also a lot of the advancements that we've talked
about relative to Hardware software and just um
modeling approaches but this was a key one too all
right all right so some of the problems with this
all right is that if you inherently increase the
temperature and this may be kind of um obvious but
if you increase that temperature um parameter all
right what you're doing essentially is selecting
but it is from a high you know high density of of
of predictions but what you're doing is you you
are selecting at random what the next best word
might be all right and so what happens is that
if for some reason that random selection of a word
right isn't exactly Perfect all right it can Reser
in in what we in what has been commonly referred
to as hallucinations right is that essentially
what happens because these things are autor
regressive which means that it's heavily dependent
on the accuracy of the previous prediction is that
once it starts to go off the rails it goes off the
rails really quickly and that can sometime result
in what we've been what we've been seeing in terms
of these hallucinations right just because the
nature of them is that they're autor regressive
right so they're using the previous previous
predictions to do the ones in the future and
if those are slightly outside of the distribution
of the data that the model has access to then it's
going to go off the rails pretty quick kind of
as we see is our comic over here right they just
don't know how deep the water is I think it's a
good way to think about we just don't know how
close we are to those errors suddenly um something
going off the side of a cliff right all right and
so this this is an example here it's kind of
a kind of a clunky graphic but I do think like
over time what's happened right is that the
models have gradually increased all right but
you always have kind of this leakage or's kind of
this dripping down here on the bottom and you can
think of the leakage as like how far can we push
these models until we realize that we see above
the surface and we're like okay this is you know
it's giving me some pretty clear hallucinations
here all right you know this was this was seen
a lot in the early days I think when gp22 was
out they acted really simple logic questions it
would just get them wrong uh and we've seen it I
think continue with gpt3 especially rela to um you
know current events things like that they're just
probably aren't in its distribution of information
that stopped in 2021 and so what's happening is I
think the models are getting better and better
it's getting deeper and deeper so the idea here
is that it's hard for us um the users to get above
that surface and really see the errors but they're
always going to kind of be there and so over time
it might be that these models are so deep that it
just never happens but it's important remember
there's always going to be a certain amount of
error kind of leaking at the bottom of these
just given the nature of how they're trained
and used which can make them and in my experience
and working with some local firms to put them into
production can make kind of difficult to use
especially if you want to have uh repeatable
authoritative information um coming out of them um
and that that that can be quite quite difficult um
okay so keep going here all right uh and then I'll
get to I'll get to potential concerns all right I
I'm conscious of the time here I think got about
another 10 minutes or so um and many of you may
have seen these I think it's important to bring
it up you know that there's kind of these open
uh and and lots of AI researchers and people
that were generating these models signed on
to some of these to have a you know kind of a
pause I think this was about a year ago to say
hey let's just wait six months I mean I don't I
don't know what six months would have would have
made any different but there are some concerns um
relative to the rapid development of these models
and there was just another one this is just an
excerpt from that letter talking about you know
that uh we're going to achieve human competitive
intelligence and a profound risk to society and
Humanity I think that's true but I think if um
you know we have a real good understanding of the
limitations of these models just like we talked
about and you start to really use them over and
over again I think think a lot of this was a bit
overstated this one maybe in particular I think
that there were some concerns I don't know people
remember this about uh the potential uh nuclear
war likee event you know if AI was uh to continue
to proliferate and maybe they're talking about
decades into the future I'm not quite uh quite as
concerned about this but it is this was signed on
by a lot of really famous um AI researchers in the
community and brought up as kind of a continuous
thing to think about at a minimum all right and
there's some misinformation that scale could be
a big problem especially with the large language
models in terms of the way that they're generating
text you know can be done quite easily and we do
we are in a period of really rapid development
and I'm just going to I'm going to let this
run I don't know if I can yeah I show you
this all right so this is a program
that's using GPT in the background but
doing kind of automated search online
so you just kind of release it to the
wild I mean even this is a bit dated
now I think this is you know kind of a
six months ago kind of an example
but I think what we're going to
see I'll just pause this all right but this is
just an example this is just a simple piece of
software that's using GPT in the background but
it's been trained in a way where it actually
goes out on the internet and starts to learn
about any particular Topic in this example
it's learning about itself actually um and then
generating summarized text based off of that so
I I think what we're going to see and this is
a good use case of it is like more and more
embedding into applications you know kind of
without without guard rails generally I think
there's been just kind of a really a push to
include this maybe maybe in spaces that make a
lot of sense but um you know in some spaces maybe
that it doesn't um and this is just the beginning
right so I think given that the technology is out
there and open you know kind of the development
around integrating it into kind of user-friendly
applications and then the combination of um uh you
know whether that's able to generate text from
prompts or generate um images from prompts or
generate um you know even um even language right
even spoken word from prompts I think it's going
to be another thing so you see these these
Integrations between audio and video and text
which is already starting to occur which could
be really exciting but also kind of um you know
a little bit a little bit scary as it relates
to kind of you know how fast these Technologies
are moving forward all right another thing uh
associated with this when we think about kind
of you know what are we concerned about is we do
have really kind of a push in the US for um you
know open development you know there's not a whole
lot of regulations this is the European model for
for people that that may be familiar with the gdpr
there that's kind of their General data protection
um you know architecture um that's available and
we don't necessarily have that in the US there's
some that's kind of close to it just California
version of it which provides for some oversight
and protection of of personal data but generally
we really don't have these restrictions which is
part of the big reason that GPT was able to um
an open AI in particular was able to develop um
these models so quickly they had so much access
to so much data basically online there was no
restrictions about what they could use we also
have a lot of competition I think so this chart
all right is an example of the parameter space
of large language models um kind of mostly from
domestic domestic kind of companies but also in
the Chinese and kind of other Global spaces and
you can see we don't necessarily have a uh a total
Market capture on this you know there there are
tons and tons of these models large language
models that are being developed and put out
into the open all right so I mean that's another
thing relative to um the space of this and the
competition which I think is it can be a really
good thing to help push these models forward and
kind of Advance development so if you put all
these kind of combinations in place you know
the competition um kind of the nature of um I'll
just go down to this you know kind of the rapid
development Global competition you know in the
free market I think what we'll see is just the the
and then the development and advance advancement
and technology and availability data we're just
going to continue to see these models kind of
grow uh and continue to proliferate over time
because of all these things that have been put put
into place um which makes it a very exciting time
to think about applications and how they can
be used in research things like that you have
to be a little bit concerned you know that there
might be some uh potential calamities associated
with all these things being put into place but uh
but you know in general I'm you know I'm fairly
bullish I think that this is going to be a toal
net positive and that you know the advancements
that we're seeing in this is going to be a uh you
know really a really um dramatic increase in our
efficiency and our ability to be able to produce
uh you know really interesting products and and
certainly push research aspects forward all right
uh so I have some final kind of specifications
here um I will say you know a regulatory framework
I think uh is is hopeful I guess the people in
conversations that a little bit more Savvy into
the space including um researchers here the school
of data science that focus on policy they believe
that a Europe like a European like model could
be present in the future in the US I'm not sure
exactly what that might look like but I think it
would probably be more of a watered down version
but I I think that would be healthy relative to
the development of these things and create some
type of guard rails you know as an example Bard
is not available in the EU right now based off
how their regulatory framework um uh is in place
it is it does seem to be clear that you know the
increased cost of keeping these models is quite
high right that it's important to remember the
latest version gp4 stops um relative to its data
set in 2021 all right by some estimations you to
train one version of this is something like the
energy used for midow you know midsize City for an
entire year um for GT4 gp4 cost close to hundred
million doar to train all right so explainability
ends up ends up being kind of a big issue relative
to this when I showed that kind of in that chart
at the very beginning to contextualize what we're
talking about as you move further and further
down kind of into the deep architectures being
able to understand exactly how they're working uh
can be quite complicated um doesn't mean that they
um don't work really well and that there aren't
some ways and I think actually explainable AI is
moving on uh pretty rapidly and I think actually
that's going to be a nice area to think about
um in terms of expansion for research areas it
almost is like a uh almost as like a push back I
think to the development of some of this kind of
generative AI that may the explainable AI space
might actually become pretty popular for some
people um to generate models that work just as
well that are a bit better understood so uh you
know I think approaches for fine-tuning AI models
and collaborations with um you know with clients
or researchers espe to be more common um you know
in my working with um with companies here and
then also you know just in talking with people
that are working to deploy these it seems that's
ends up being um the majority of the time you
know because you have kind of these pre-trained
models already and you can pick them up and use
them but then fine tuning them on the back end
for your particular use case you know kind of a
reinforced learning approach ends up being um the
majority of the work and uh I think that's good
and I think it also at some places you know need
to create a um you know a framework for at what
point does it not make sense to continue to try
and do that right and maybe use another approach
that doesn't require so much fine-tuning and I
think that that's a that's a space where people
are going to start to make choices about whether
they want to use generative AI or maybe to go back
to more I mean I guess we could say this you know
more traditional kind of AI approaches that don't
necessarily require you know the generation of
new of new text or images or sound or Voice or
video whatever that might be um so I think that
so that's it I I went through that really really
kind of fast but um Jack I think I got is that 15
minutes for questions is that kind of the way that
we go yes perfect Brian thank you thank you so
much for giving us this overview I this was really
helpful for me and helping to give me a little
more of the context um certainly it seems like
in the last oh 18 months or so I mean the last
nine months we have seen just such an explosion
with you know it's like one of these things where
a sequel to a movie comes out and it's like you
know son of zor you know returns again right he
like well what was the original zor movie I didn't
see that one but now there's like I'm seeing the
advertising for the sequel It's like chat gpt3 I
didn't know there were several others before that
and so it's like seems like it's just arrived so
it's so sudden and I'm wondering if that's part
of one of the drivers of people's fears about this
is it just seems like it happened over night
yeah 100% I mean I I and it it just it when I
started to look look into this and I was trying
to better understand it myself I mean me I mean
me and you are both in schools of data science
and to a certain extent like the explosion of of
this even caught us off guard I mean I think it
did you know so uh we spent a lot of time doing
kind of like a like a postto and be like whoa how
did this how did this happen I mean part of it
was just relative to the the ease of use of that
of chat GPT uh in particular um just made it it
made it very accessible and so even these methods
you know they were kind of in place in house in
these big Tech firms you know when that became
online and the user interface became so simple
then people just that that was a big reason for it
but also I think when we started to look back it
like had the Slow Burn kind of and maybe not even
slow right but kind of the rapid development of of
Technologies and software and data expansion
in the last like seven to eight years it was
almost like Manifest Destiny that as soon as the
technology as soon as the mathematical approaches
the AI architecture became available it just took
off because everything else was in place yeah and
um that just made it you know it made essentially
the foundation for kind of sharpening the pointy
end of that spear possible because before you
know maybe maybe it's a bad but the spear just
didn't really exist and then all of a sudden
it was there and it allowed it to um to really
explode yeah it's interesting how these perfect
storms of things kind of can happen right it's
only when you had the Confluence of all of these
different Technologies just all were you know at
there at the same time that they got put together
and then there's just this explosion of innovation
in this area it's fascinating yeah and the other
really interesting thing people people don't talk
about it enough is that how how the big Tech firms
espe esally for the attention vehicle open sourced
those Innovations and that allowed open AI the
company at that time to take the innovations
that were generated in Google and create GPT
I mean so if that hadn't been like an open you
know research process they never would have been
able to leverage that technology to accomplish and
now they have a multi-billion dollar company as
a result of it which is also really interesting
yeah you know and it's interesting you know you
were talking about what the cost is to train these
models and you know that it takes the power of a
small nation to be able to do as probably a lot of
money as well but you still have these phenomenon
like uh you know the models hallucinating and
one of our uh comments from one of our viewers is
asking like how do you tell the difference between
a model that just wasn't trained on something
and just doesn't happen to know versus it's
hallucinating how do you tell the difference it's
a good question essentially it's the same thing
so what we find is that hallucinations occur in
particular when prompts are given um to large
language models when the answers are outside of
a density of distribution of information that has
available so like as an example like if we know
that uh you know gp4 was trained on information
prior to 2021 it knows a lot about presidents it
can tell you a ton about presidential procedure
like the history like what the Presidential Power
it could do a lot about that but it can't really
tell you a lot about how Biden implements his
version of his presidential you know presidential
Powers right because it doesn't have a lot of
density of information on him in particular
right so that's that's that's kind of what we see
is that those hallucinations have a tendency to
occur um because of there's not enough information
in the distribution of data that it has available
to it and that's why you see a lot of energy going
into fine-tuning you know and it's almost like
it's almost like whacka all you know like you you
you push these you push these models and push them
and push them and then all of a sudden there's
another set of information that it just doesn't
it just doesn't know enough about it to accurately
generate text around that so you have to kind of
put a bandaid on it and say all right well let's
eliminate this from the range of things that it
could ask and that's when you get the prompt and
say hey I'm not too sure on this you know you may
want to think about asking it another way and so
that's that's where kind of that you know how you
F to to end of those models to make sure that
they're not don't have an expansive kind of uh
perimeter set you know that kind of control the
span of the things that they have expertise on
and don't but when you're talking about you know
training it on the entire Internet it's almost
impossible to do that you know to say hey these
are things that can know and not know so the the
hallucination effect is essentially infinite
because you can't go in and and correct every
possible um error that might occur yeah you know
and another thing which is kind of interesting is
you might think okay how could it you know keep
up with its knowledge base right so you might
imagine that it would pick a number of you know
New York Times or CNN or whatever your favorite
news source is and ingest that information and use
it in training its models but then of course the
the chat GPT and other Technologies like this are
generating the content um in you know where might
expect that they would in the future generating
that same content you almost get this sense of
like a snake eating its own tail in terms of its
training at some point you know uh a human being
in the loop is probably important somehow how do
we keep a Reign on that is that even a sensible
question no no it makes it makes a lot of sense
and it it hearkens back to kind of a first mover
in this you know you know ethics of data science
field which was which Kathy which Kathy O'Neal Who
Affiliated here um at UVA um and she you know put
out this book called weapons of maass Destruction
and one of the four key components associated
with you know an algorithm that maybe has gone Ry
is essentially it's it's eating its own dog food
right and so it's generating information that then
gets put back in to the training set and then is
used for generating you know predictions uh moving
forward that it's affected the landscape of the
information it receives so much that it's actually
generating um the information that it gets trained
on and that's that's like you said like the snake
eating its tail so I I think it at one at at
some point what starts which just like any
other algorithm that gets put out into the wild
regardless of how big it is you know it may cost
a hundred million dollars but and and you have to
keep track of how often these errors are occurring
like how often is it hallucinating and recently
actually there's been a lot of interesting
research at least you know kind of um you know
maybe you know desktop research associated with
the idea that GPT is actually getting Dumber you
know is that things that it was getting right
not that long ago it's starting to get wrong now
and that it's starting to essentially it's this
you know enthropy principle right is that as the
expansion of the things that it's being asked to
do continues to grow it's just getting worse and
worse at it and then at some point you just need
to stop and retrain yeah yeah exactly it's it's
almost a continuous training process right it's it
can't you can't just train it then use it and it's
going to slowly drift out of out of alignment or
out of calibration right it needs to be calibrated
but on a continuous basis in order to just keep up
yeah I think it's exactly that and then with
the scale of cost associated with with doing
that retraining you have you have to start to
think that um you know is that model sustainable
I mean I I don't know I mean it it it might not
be um and so then I think you know there's been
a there's been kind of a movement especially with
some of the the examples I've seen to get away
from using the all-encompassing Corpus of uh large
language models trained on the entire internet and
then do much more specialized training you know
in terms of more local Corp ey that you can use
so it's really good and that this is the same
thing that happened with go and chess like all
these they're trained on a very discrete data set
and as a result it's quite good at that one thing
right um so I think there's been some been at
least in conversations I've had with people that
are working to develop these there's been kind of
a movement towards that I was struck by the thing
you commented on early in your presentation about
that the there was was one amateur chess player
or something who found one little Innovation that
nobody had found and he was able to then beat the
the large the learning model you know 19 out of 20
times or something you know because the computer
is just following its instruction set right it's
following its learning model and but somebody
goes hey wait a minute if I do this I upset it it
reminded me of the uh the self-driving taxis and
I can't remember where it is I think it's in is
it New Orleans or something where somebody found
if they take a a traffic cone one of those orange
traffic cones and they put it on the hood of the
of the car as a joke it stops the car the car does
not know how to handle that and it stops dead in
its tracks and they create traffic jams it's like
you know who thought of that that's amazing but it
it's means now that they have to go back retrain
their models and say you know ignore traffic cones
yeah and then think about the think about the
differences between like the computer vision space
that would be needed to have an automated car have
enough density of information to understand and
interpret every potential scenario that it could
run into I mean that again seems Seems infinite
you know and uh maybe that's why we you know
the realization of the dream of the driverless
car just really hasn't hasn't shown up quite yet
and and that example with go um it was done by a
research firm in um affiliated with Stanford um
and it was an amateur player and and I don't I
don't know the game go but essentially what it
did is created a you know a perimeter around a
particular move and that if you are if you if it
was a human playing against a human it would have
recognized it immediately as a you know kind of a
fairly in non-sophisticated move inside the game
and counteracted it immediately but because the
to your point because the alphao had never seen
this you know it's kind of a kind of a a move
you would never make in personto person play
because it would be so easily recognizable right
that it defeated the computer because it just had
never seen it before and so it's this idea that we
think about these machines as intelligent but it's
really it's not it doesn't learn the rules of the
game it just learns patterns of success so if a
pattern of success doesn't exist it doesn't have
any intuition about what the rules are to defeat
new methods and that's an important thing it is
intelligent in a way but it not intuitive about
the rules or how to play the game only only
super understanding of the classical patterns
for Success which is a you know so you can put
quotations around intelligence in that context
at least from my perspective yeah Ron what are
the what's the important elements here about
making and keeping Innovations in the development
of these models open source yeah I mean there's a
there's a cultural Community associated with that
that reinforces it but I I I think that that could
be part of um I I think I'll say this we used the
use case of open AI you know in kind of some of
our foundations courses because it was open until
it wasn't right until it was evaluated as a as a
billion doll Enterprise and then now it's not
a an open- Source platform right so they went
private they started taking equity and then they
got bought by Microsoft so I mean it so it it was
a pretty easy transition for them you know once
it became clear that you know there were billions
of dollars at stake but I think like other I
mean in other areas of our economy you know
you think about the entire industry around ni and
then how we you know we don't deploy um you know
new medicines I mean even even around accounting
principles you know about what it what's required
in order for us to be you know financial advisors
things like that I mean these might be extremes
but you really don't have any of that relative to
developing algorithms and putting them out in the
world or or you know um you know data regulatory
oversight that seems like there should be so I I
think to a certain extent um in order for this
to be an open conversation for continue to be
you know known um is that it's going to require
some type of governmental intervention because
the the dollars we're talking about here are just
too big um for you know even even companies that
have idealistic idealistic uh origination like
open AI did to not suddenly go private once it
becomes obvious that that's the the best the best
way for them to go and so I don't know if I have
a great answer for that but I think to me there
should be some regulatory kind of um function
that allows um you know some oversight about how
these are being trained how they're being deployed
and then exactly what methodologies they're using
in order to be able to keep an informed populace
about about how they're being used I think
that would be a healthy step no Brian thank
you so much for sharing uh today and providing
a context for generative AI um especially as we
go down this uh Road of building Partnerships
between folks who are developing generative AI
methodologies and the biomedical and clinical
research training that is soon to be following
um utilizing these methods thank you so much
for kicking us off and uh I want to um thanks
everybody who joined us out in the world and uh
please uh watch next week uh when we have our
next edition of our biomedical data science
uh seminaries so thanks so much again Brian